thank you for staying with us so far
so far what did I tell you segment what
did I tell you please take a look
bar
Bandits shutting up now
yep yep yep yep
what the heck is that
there are new mutations at all over the
place looks like
were those corrupted chica Towers
thank you
the cabins are mining right look at the
rise my servants get an earth voice
sweep over High roll eliminate this
Kingdom and her allies get into his
voice leave no survivors oh whoa
oh my God
get him link where's Zelda somebody show
me Zelda
what the whoa
[Music]
whoa what is that
[Applause]
clink
sure
you'll be able to stop him
don't you underestimate him
whoa what was that you got some sort of
homing thing now
that was hylia
[Music]
my brain
there's a
[Music]
please lend him your power
was that two links that I just saw there
oh my gosh oh my God